l'ue pour soutenir monsieur turquie
était un candidat que je connais bien et
montrer qu'on est sincère de nature où
il est resté à deux reprises gérald
darmanin aura donc écorché le nom du
candidat qu'il est venu soutenir denis
thuriau donné quatrième dans les
sondages et en manque de notoriété
ce matin le renfort d'un poids lourd du
gouvernement étaient attendus pendant
quelques heures
le ministre de l'intérieur fait campagne
aux côtés de la tête de liste et
l'hérault m un déplacement très vite
dénoncée par le candidat du
rassemblement national julien odoul qui
parle de tourisme électoral
moi je suis un élu local je soutiens les
candidats la majorité qu'est ce que je
vous dise que monsieur d'où le souk eu
peut-être des ferments de provocation et
s occupe plus d habitants de la région
et puis si on ce combat contre des idées
c'est mieux quand les personnes donc
voilà qui garde son calme c'est mieux
[Applaudissements]
dans ce meeting
denis thuriau et gérald darmanin parle
beaucoup sécurité et présente la liste
et les rues m comme un barrage au parti
de marine le pen en quelques semaines
pour mobiliser les électeurs se sont
gérald darmanin olivier véran mêmes
emmanuel macron qui se sont affichés au
côté du maire de nevers faut croire que
j'ai une grande confiance de leur part
et je leur rend bien
et ils viennent surtout soutenir un
territoire un territoire qui est en
danger
on connaît les thématiques du
rassemblement national qui sont la
démagogie et chasserait l'enterrement du
développement de la bourgogne franche
comté pour nous pour nos enfants pour
nos petits enfants je pense pas que ce
soit ce que veulent nos concitoyens dans
une semaine
jean castex est attendu à besançon pour
soutenir lui aussi denis curio à trois
jours du premier tour